welcome to this video playing Grand
Master croup you a Koopa from here
Jordan the John and flick it did not
play him too often recently wonder if
his maybe are not so active anymore
where's played many games in the last
couple of days but somehow we we didn't
didn't meet okay and that's let's check
oh it's not playing the Kings Indian but
sort of hybrid modern set up against
Bishop g4 III this is quite quite a
decent line at son should I am yeah I
don't want to Castle so quickly I like
them the idea to UM to have maybe g4 h4
available if he castles if we castles
King side like for instance if you would
castle now ya hear this g4 can be an
idea it is some especially interesting
because he has given up the light
squared Bishop which means that f five
is even tougher to play okay I'll do
that the only risk is of course that my
development is lagging a bit this trades
um in a way structure for further Nemec
seemed he might have some some things
that he can do because of his better
development yeah b5 before being one of
them okay I'm going for a g5 here right
g5 age for gaining the space and also by
kicking on the knight on f6 away I'm
able to lessen the pressure a bit from
reform so b5 before I might be able to
just move the night away
not having problems on them on the e4
pawn his problems as the space of this
lame ok so just age five yeah why not
why not really one problem is if I
capture on g6 and he would recapture
with the f porn there is this Bishop g4
to e6 idea which is really am which has
gained a lot in strength because the
lightscribe bishops his light squared
Bishop is gone yes yeah he's got he's
got this nice square since I'm some
source of counter play some night g3 on
is this misplaced the night is not doing
much on g3 besides covering e4 but this
is a good job anyway I'll do that so
that the bishop on f3 can be used on e2
or on G form yeah well this is
interesting is going he tries to go nite
b5 to deform that's a good a good plan
for for counter play
yes so don't like age 6 mm yeah that's
not not clear this position not at all
night b-52 d4 it's a very good counter
play maybe maybe I really must just take
it out 95 I'm taking it cannot allow it
to d4 I don't don't don't see how now
maybe just try to complete development
my general idea which is probably too
slow maybe Nick sking f 1 G 2 and then
Quincy 4-h for kicking to g2 because of
93 so I want to get out of this this
stuff I'm in the end in this young this
was clear that this was happening I
probably have to move the king in any
case yeah this is what I expected this
counter play I don't really know how so
strong it is go here
yes he wants to enter on the sea
fathered not possible at the moment i
know i will have this play on the edge
phone that's interesting trying to get
the night to see form now i don't like
to take it does not feel right and to be
three yellow maybe be three okay you
will enter on c3 year with the rook
we're not clear not clear how bad this
really is a reaction i can i can start
with this I can start with this first
and now or should I even should I even
ignore that and just like to put
everything on the H file okay well this
is this is probably produce anyway I
know is going all the way back
ok
and one never play look here I can start
with this probably may I should i played
real time learning age for instead okay
well now i don't have much choice
okay if he goes yeah look aged 79
probably and then go into edge form
night f8 I can take a queen edge for
this is strong Oh check tweenage a check
made it's a bit that that's something
okay if I take it check here check here
King down I can take a five and a half o
gauge and I take with the porn king edge
7 i'm not so sure ok so I'm I'll do that
Jack Guiney aids has the only move
anyway what is he doing crook h8 route
f7 I have Queenie 6 check okay okay we
have seven Queenie 6 check black resign
yes yeah that's good since it's made
it's a maid okay 7kg 6 p-8 Queen f7 s is
gone and this is check also magnate it
was too much on the edge far and really
believe not quite sure what the
computers giving oh my why very high
scores yeah what during the game you
knew you always a bit unsure can he may
be defined or whatever but the computer
is giving queen g 4 plus 3 and it's
probably a figure that is only going to
go go high as it gets deeper and
calculation Roxy a drug h1 plus 50 cage
seven yeah this is the right way rock
edge 7 is winning no plus 15 and this is
your first made already
yeah that's nice yeah well I thought
that I'm really really in good shape him
it's just just a good position I thought
but this was a good counter play Knights
is seven to be five really good I'm not
sure about we should be too and taking
but jack knight on d4 is just not
tolerable really maybe around here can
start you to look for improvements I
mean I know Queen f5 it's not bleeding
too much at the end I mean King f1 g2 is
useful anyway because 93 is such an
annoying thing I need to get out of the
check okay it's not there's not much
happening on the queenside really almost
I wasn't sure about this move but we
should d 2 is also interesting pointed
out by the computer yeah because this is
a very annoying pin and a 2 a 3 sio
threat still a threat I are interesting
move ok b3 and around here around here
it gets very critical it's hard to tell
at which point like is really beyond
saving here the computer is only giving
me a slight edge but it's a that's a
matter of calculation depth really
because it takes a while I mean look at
shree rook h1 Queen g4 and so on the
couple of moves until I have my stuff
set up on the edge far and black it's
maybe not so easy for even for the
computer to to see if it is fatal or not
but it gets to fatal really quickly like
here plus 2
probably roxy 79 roxy 3s the computer
move now maybe intending to to do
something like that on or let's say
quincy form night f8 I don't really
don't really know if there is a big
difference if I just do this pile up
again okay here here we see the counter
play check okay yeah this is this is
Sarah a completely different animal as
black is entering my position so this is
why rocsi three years probably the
better defense and jam wait probably I
need to do something else
Bishop d to this is this is also
possible at here because it checked
probably back somewhere maybe here even
10 day would be three yeah odds this
this position should also be quite good
for like I tough to analyze it certainly
has some defensive resources still
available shouldn't probably shouldn't
lose like directly but it's quicker
brooksy seven has already gone it seems
I'm too quick on the edge farm very nice
that's also an interesting attacking
idea actually with did I just spot it if
i go here just for argument sake its is
trying to just try to show you this and
now queen queen f6 and just spotted this
idea just wanted to show it can be a
useful attacking idea okay Jade may
threaten and this this is also also over
not force but just to show this idea
alright thanks for watching